ground news is combating divisiveness in
media ground is a news comparison
platform that helps you see multiple
perspectives for any news story so you
can be more of a well-rounded news
reader download the free app at
ground.newslash Pacman welcome to the
show we're getting back into one of
those phases very much reminiscent of
2020 where things are changing
relatively quickly when it comes to the
pandemic and the trajectory over the
next two three four five months and part
of the question that has been
increasingly asked is will there be a
third vaccine dose will there be a
recommendation for some or maybe even
most people to get a third dose of the
coronavirus vaccine in order to have
stronger protection against the Delta
variant and or future variants and over
the last 24 hours the answer seems to
increasingly be point pointing to yes
let's review a couple of articles about
this CNN article Pfizer data
suggests third dose of covid-19 vaccine
strongly boosts protection against Delta
variant now there are some important
details here let's review a third dose
of the Pfizer biontec covid-19 vaccine
can strongly boost protection against
the Delta variant beyond the protection
afforded by the standard two doses new
data released by Pfizer on Wednesday
suggests the data posted online suggests
that levels of antibodies that can
Target the Delta variant grow five-fold
in people age 18 to 55.
who get a third dose of the vaccine
among people ages 65 to 85 the Pfizer
data suggests antibody levels that
should protect against Delta grow 11 for
fold more than following a second dose
now it's not likely that in older folks
they get to a higher level of antibodies
it's that because in older folks it's
looking like the antibodies start to
diminish it is getting them up at a
greater multiple because they are
starting with a lower base rate it's
just a simple mechanism of of
understanding the base rate understand
that this is this is the key line the
data involve tests of 23 people
and have not yet been peer reviewed or
published it is very very early in this
but there are other countries studying
this as well which we will get to in a
moment so if you were wondering why does
your CDC vaccination card have more than
two slots even though up until now the
protocol has been two doses this may
well be why
um it's another important
um detail it's not clear if boosted
antibody levels actually correlate to
better protection or if that extra
protection is even needed the uscdc and
prevention the uscdc says the current
vaccines protect people well against all
the common variants so there's a bunch
of different factors here one is
does Pfizer have a financial interest in
everybody getting a third dose sure you
could say that that there's no question
about that they stand to make a lot of
money
if all of a sudden instead of two doses
for every American it's three doses for
every American and people in other
countries as well uh the other question
is even with diminished antibodies do
you have enough antibodies that you
would still in most cases be immune or
at least unlikely to get seriously ill
because that's the point of a vaccine if
we say if cases mean mostly colds and
vaccinated people cases become less
important it's sort of like well it's
like cases of the flu cases of colds Etc
we've talked about that before we don't
need to go over it again needless to say
other countries are also investigating
this third dose idea uh and Israel is
going to be moving forward on it
um as you can see here the Israeli
Health Ministry recommends a third
coveted shot for older Israelis most
experts on the committee argue for a
coveted booster shot for Israeli 60 and
above as the Delta variant spreads
experts advising the health Ministry
have recommended that older people
receive a third dose of the coronavirus
vaccine though they disagree on whether
the cohort should start at 60 years old
65 or 70. some of the data presented at
a discussion Wednesday suggested that
the vaccine's effectiveness in
preventing severe symptoms among 60 year
olds and above has dropped to 81 percent
from 97 percent in January
While most panel members favored a
booster shot for anyone 60 or older
others suggested that the Barbie raised
to 65 or 70. the health ministries
director General will make the final
decision we are seeing a dramatic drop
in the level of immunity and we know the
elderly respond less to vaccines than
the young but we don't have this data
for covid-19
Tuesday the Prime Minister declared
Israel was very close to making a
decision on covet booster shots and on
obtaining additional doses needed so
for me there is every indication here
that we're going in the direction of a
third dose at least for some portion of
the U.S population
even though there is still some lack of
clarity about even if your antibodies
diminish you may still have enough
antibodies to mostly protect you from
the disease and again this is one of
those situations where other countries
are saying third doses guys were
desperate for some vaccines send us
anything we'll take anything we'll even
give us first doses for some people and
in the U.S we have this incredibly an
extraordinarily privileged situation
where anybody can just walk in and get a
first dose and a second dose if there's
a decision made about third doses that
that we go in the direction of yes
those are going to be widely available
and yet tons of people in the United
States still don't even want to go and
get vaccinated we are also fortunately
and it's only a slight Improvement but
fortunately we are starting to see
vaccination numbers go up in the United
States over the last couple of days we
had a couple consecutive days where
there were about 375
000 uh new vaccinations meaning not when
it's a two-dose regimen if you just look
at the number of doses you don't know
how many people that represents about
375
000 new people per day going and getting
a vaccine now you look at that and you
say oh my goodness that's 0.1 percent of
the population that's an improvement and
it's very depressing when we could be
vaccinating tens of millions of more
people but the fact that the numbers are
going in the right direction rather than
the wrong direction is certainly
something that we can be glad about so
that's the latest on third doses what I
want to talk about next is increasingly
understand the framing here businesses
making decisions that they judge are
good business decisions for them okay
let's get into that next
no shirt
no shoes no vaccine no service okay that
is legally something that businesses can
say in the same way that you can have
requirements for going into a business
that might include you've got to be
wearing shoes or you've got to be
wearing a shirt for public health
purposes for sanitation purposes
businesses can say you've got to be
vaccinated against covet 19. we've seen
this start in other countries and we're
now seeing it start in the United States
restaurants tell customers no vacs no
service as Delta variant spreads this is
an interesting article from MarketWatch
as covid cases increase
establishments are requiring customers
to prove they are fully vaccinated and
they're running into protests in the
process not surprisingly as covid-19
cases surged through the U.S a growing
number of dining and drinking
establishments are turning unvaccinated
customers away saying their businesses
can't risk possibly exposing patrons and
staff to the virus but these novax no
service decisions have sparked
controversy with anti-vaccination groups
and individuals saying they constitute a
violation of civil rights some states
such as Florida and Texas have enacted
laws that essentially prevent private
businesses from imposing these bans on
the unvaccinated on today's bonus show
we will talk about despite what
Republican trumpian Governor Ron
DeSantis has done in Florida trying to
ban any such vaccine requirements Mayors
all over Florida in different parts of
Florida
are defying Ron Ron DeSantis and saying
no let's do the vaccine requirements
let's allow the vaccine requirements
anyway we'll talk about that on today's
bonus show uh the bars and restaurants
putting the vaccine requirements in
place range from individually owned ones
to small chains in San Francisco a local
bar owner organization representing more
than 300 establishments announced Monday
it's calling for bar customers to show
proof of vaccination or a negative covet
test to enter bars Italy has started
doing this parts of Spain are going to
be doing this France I'm sorry France
not Italy Italy maybe is is going to do
it I'm not actually sure on Italy
um patrons who don't meet the
requirement will be allowed to sit
outside at local drinking spots Ben
blyman president of the San Francisco
bar owner Alliance and a bar proprietor
himself said it is hard to ignore the
fact that covid-19 can easily be spread
by unvaccinated individuals so at a time
when there is a dramatic rise in cases
the ban is simply necessary it seems to
be the easiest and fastest way to
protect people
he said
City Winery a national bar and
restaurant chain that offers live music
by prominent artists actually our friend
Matisyahu is soon going to be playing
some City Winery gigs in New York and I
believe in Boston City Winery already
had a vaccine requirement in place for
its New York City location after
surveying customers throughout the
country over the last few days by email
it is decided to extend the requirement
at all its establishments starting next
week
um more than 75 percent of customers who
responded to the survey supported the
vaccine requirement he also said that
when he is at his New York City venue
and talks to those on hand before a
performance he gets a standing ovation
uh this is going to be the new battle
this is going to be the new battle and
we are later I'm going to show you it's
going to look like it's a five-year-old
it's actually a full-grown adult
going on a complete tantrum about masks
on the floor of the House of
Representatives we are going to see a
certain contingent of the American
population go absolutely cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs based on here we go now
businesses not regulated in this way by
the government in other words the
government is not regular some states
are trying to but the government is not
regulating businesses insofar as telling
them you must or you cannot or whatever
put in place a vaccine requirement
businesses are deciding for themselves
the way Republicans claim they want
businesses to be able to do hey are we
better off overall with a vaccine
requirement to come to our establishment
or not and if people see the vaccine
requirement and they say that's terrible
sir we hate it then they can choose not
to go to that establishment the business
is able to make the decision they
believe is best for them they may be
right they may be wrong but it's their
there right to make that decision
and then you as a consumer can say I
want to reward this business with my
money voting with my dollars because I
like their rule or I am going to avoid
this business you might choose to avoid
a business because they do have a
vaccine requirement you might choose to
avoid a business because they do not
have a vaccine requirement and either
way everybody is making the choice that
is best for them you don't have a right
to go unvaccinated to a private
restaurant it will be up to you to
figure out where you want to go now
that's that's the libertarian small
government you know uh argument for what
is going on I have a sense that
so-called small government conservatives
are not going to take it the way that I
am laying it out they're going to say
it's a violation of the Constitution
it's a violation of HIPAA hippo Rhino
elephant giraffe whatever right they'll
they'll come up with what it's a
violation I've been violated
um and uh it is going to be the latest
72 96 hour Scandal on right-wing media
that's the expectation I assume by
Monday we're going to start to see it
speaking of important Mondays by the way
we are now one two I guess three Mondays
away from the 16th anniversary of the
David Pacman show also known as the 16
year wait no 16-year anniversary is uh
that's that you know that's an oxymoron
right 16-year anniversary it's the 16th
anniversary that I'm sure of uh it will
be Monday August 16th we are doing a one
day membership special we're calling it
a membership bomb but it's a bomb only
in the in the best sense there's nothing
violent of any kind
um and if you're interested in signing
up at an extreme discount to celebrate
this 16 year anniversary uh please sign
up for my newsletter at davidpackman.com
and then Monday August 16th you'll be
notified hey here is how you sign up and
take advantage of the discount
I've been on Fox News a couple of times
if I'm ever invited back ground news is
one of the first things I would use to
get my head in the game and prepare
myself for the interview because ground
news is a news source comparison
platform that lets you compare how
Outlets from the left right and Center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story and it also shows you
your news blind spot stories that your
side of the political Spectrum may not
have covered ground news can help you
build a well-crafted argument for
debating people you disagree with or
ground news can help you discover
something new about your own perspective
challenging your own strongly held views
on political issues be the most informed
person in the room download the free
ground news app today by going to ground
dot News slash Pacman
all right we we just have too much to
get to today for me to spend the next 20
minutes talking about membership so I
won't I hope people will accept my
apology and and people I'm sure we're
looking forward to that let's get right
into some notable discussions from the
David packman show subreddit you can
join more than 32 000 of our viewers and
listeners on the subreddit
davidpackman.com r-e-d-d-i-t
um join the discussion and a lot of
important things being discussed there
here is a question that has been coming
up a lot and there was a very
interesting uh discussion and poll of
our audience the question is do you guys
have any sympathy for anti-vaxxers who
wind up getting sick with covid-19 and
we're gonna look at such a story in a
moment and the the majority in our
audience said no but I don't wish death
on anybody or no they should have known
better so a lot of not feeling any
sympathy for people who don't get
vaccinated and later get sick
um some in the audience said I have a
little bit of sympathy but not much and
by far the least common answer among our
audience was yes I do have sympathy for
the anti-vaxxers who get sick and I hope
they all have a speedy recovery I'm sort
of in that Minority and I understand
that there is a significant level of uh
of ignorance and
um a disconnection from reality in many
of these people but I do consider
themselves victims and I know the Eggman
will call in and say David you're too
empathetic that's not going to get you
anywhere maybe that's the case but
um I think that I mean listen I think
it's totally normal to resent the
anti-vaxxers there is no doubt about it
they're extending this we have
widespread vaccines available here
and they're choosing not to get one and
this furthers the spread and it
increases death and it increases
hospitalization I get it so I understand
resenting but also when I hear that
someone like for example pro-trump
anti-vaxx radio host Phil Valentine is
now on a ventilator which we will talk
about in a moment uh I don't I don't
feel good about it it doesn't make me
that I don't like that
um so uh that's the point of view I
guess of the audience another post from
the subreddit called clearing up the
arguments over mask squaring brings up a
couple of interesting questions and it
says now that the CDC is recommending
indoor mask wearing again even for
vaccinated Americans I'm already seeing
the insane outrage in ignorance from
conservatives we saw last year I thought
this would be a good subreddit to make
sense of the issue because I feel like
I'm losing my mind so I'm just clearing
this up feel free to discuss
there's plenty of evidence to show that
the vaccinated coveted patients do not
end up in the hospital in fact they
experience very little symptoms this is
like the flu shot right I remember the
one year I didn't get the flu shot I got
the flu I was bedridden for a week I got
the flu this last year with a flu shot
had a minor headache and sniffles this
is the way to debunk any argument
stating the vaccines don't work see we
told you
then you have the mask wearing why would
I wear a mask if I'm if I'm vaccinated
well because you can still transmit it
to the unvaccinated we might have some
people say they don't care about giving
it to unvaccinated people which honestly
I find perfectly okay but that's the
reason the CDC is recommending masks
right lastly why do these conservatives
think mask wearing is about government
control I don't get it Biden hasn't
taken advantage of government control at
all that's what they always said it's a
slippery slope no they're just going to
want you to wear a mask because we
haven't 100 defeated this thing right
it's insane to me how little I can
empathize with their views right now
unless I'm the crazy one which is what
I'd like you all to help me with because
to me these people must be very very
stupid and lack any critical thinking
skills how is it possible to reason with
them how you can't and so the pretzel
that you find yourself in trying to talk
to these people and saying how can I
just get them to get it why don't they
understand it unfortunately we can both
feel sympathy and empathy for people who
get sick
and resent them and be going out of our
minds because any conversation with them
is an exercise in futility and
frustration and Desperation it's all of
the above and you know there's this
concept from uh I don't know if it's I
don't know if I don't know what area of
psychotherapy it's from but it's
basically being able to hold two
conflicting ideas at the same time right
you know in a relationship it might be
that you find yourself incredibly angry
at someone who hasn't treated you right
but yet you still love them because
they're family or whatever the case
maybe and you've got to kind of hold
both ideas it's the same thing here and
the word empathy keeps coming up we can
both empathize and sympathize with
people who are getting sick without
being vaccinated and be mad resentful
and frustrated up to the Wazoo because
of those very same people I think it
makes absolutely perfect sense join the
discussion weigh in yourself at
davidpackman.com Reddit all right um I'm
going to show you video here
of an adult this is a full grown human
Republican Congressman chip Roy from
Texas throwing a tantrum the likes of
which you would expect from a
two-year-old in a sandbox about what
about mask wearing uh given the new
guidance from the CDC about the spread
of the Delta variant in great part
because of unvaccinated people the House
of Representatives is looking at
reimposing a mask requirement on the
floor of the house and in fact I believe
they have done it there are some members
that are protesting it one such member
is Chip Roy you will notice if you're
watching that like a toddler Marjorie
Taylor green this is such an
attention-seeking behavior in ASB
um I know a lot of people who
participate in these attention-seeking
Behavior behaviors you know who I'm
talking about it's you go to a
restaurant and there's someone at the
next table over talking really really
loudly about how much money they make or
how smart they are or the vacation they
went on not for the benefit of the
people at their table but for the bank
benefit of the people at surrounding
tables it's in a set attention-seeking
Behavior Marjorie Taylor green does this
all the time on the house floor when
when the debate is about masks or
vaccines or abortion or whatever she
plants herself right behind the person
who is speaking and ranting that's going
on here let's listen to chip Roy
absolutely loses mind this is not a
two-year-old folks take a look here on
the people
we gotta go around
animal Duty unless I wear a mask which
is it vaccines or masks does he not
understand it or he is he pretending not
to understand it the vaccines work or
they don't work do the maths work so
they don't work I'd like to know which
it is I'd like Dr fauci to come down and
answer a single question about natural
immunity and then you see Marjorie
Taylor green nodding like chip Roy's uh
uh making some kind of incredibly
Salient Point here
oh but sorry the vaccine doesn't work
you must wear a mask this institution is
a sham and we should adjourn and shut
this place down and so they're a
Marjorie Taylor green standing up and uh
cheering and clapping and so on so this
was the point they wanted to adjourn the
house proceedings over the mask
guidelines I mean it's sort of like the
Congressional equivalent of if I can't
play in the sandbox I'm gonna poop in it
so nobody else can either right uh
apologies for the I'm still thinking of
that Pastor playing with the dog poop
yesterday and then we move on to Kevin
McCarthy Kevin McCarthy Mark McCarthy is
the House minority leader and it gives
me great pleasure to call him the
minority leader because Republicans did
lose control of the house
um and he goes on a rant about all the
things he claims Democrats want to
control I don't even know where he's
getting this stuff but it's just like
their philosophy they want a mandate
they want to impose they want to tell
you when you can go to school when you
can eat when you can eat that does
anybody know know what that's about is
that about like lunch times at school is
there actually something he's referring
to or is that just more trash gutter
trash from these people
you know what they're gonna do if you
walk into this building without a mask
they're going to charge you 500 why
because they got the power to do it
how ominous what an ominous thing now
there was one guy and I just absolutely
love this there was one guy who wasn't
having any of this garbage and it's our
friend Tim Ryan Tim Ryan has been a
guest on the show really interesting guy
you know you don't have to agree with
him on every single policy but just you
know he's an informed guy he has
interests he's intellectually curious he
knows about mindfulness he knows about
alternative energy he's just a good guy
delivering an impassioned takedown of
these absurd Republicans take a look at
this somebody represents the hot spots
right and they get in a plane and they
fly here and they interact with all of
us and then we leave here and we go home
to our families
some take care of their sick parents
some take care of kids who may have an
autoimmune disorder
and I just find it absolutely immature
and appalling to somehow diminish it to
try to score cheap political points
right and that's exactly what we saw a
few minutes ago well yeah that is
beneath a minority leader of one of the
major political parties in the United
sort of not anymore in other words
trumpianism has reduced the dialogue so
much that it's actually no longer
beneath the Republican party to do what
they they did earlier United States of
America saying we should take no
caution oh that someone from a hot spot
a hot spot is working in this chamber
and could potentially get someone
infected that could go home to a sick
parent or a immune compromised kid
that is beneath us
that is beneath us
and it's certainly beneath leadership
here in Washington D.C it should be but
unfortunately it is just par for the
course now this is how trumpian politics
Works Uh Kevin McCarthy is a absolutely
perfect example of that so an absolute
mess on the house floor and these people
and by the way many of these people are
vaccinated even though they talk about
oh mandatory Jabs and all they're
vaccinated they're back but if they were
to just say it
um they would suffer politically that's
the reality and so many of them are
hiding their own vaccination we'll
actually get back to that a little bit
later I do want to update people on
another one of these anti-vaxx pro-trump
people who is very sick with covet it's
actually getting worse I don't like to
hear this I told you about radio host
Phil Valentine Phil Valentine was a he
says he was vaccine skeptical
it's basically an anti-vaxxer okay
um and pro-trump guy told you earlier
this week that he was very sick with
covet hospitalized and on oxygen but his
family and the radio station where he
works made it a point to say he is not
on a ventilator that has now changed
Phil Valentine is now on a ventilator
amid his covid-19 battle
conservative radio talk show host Phil
Valentine currently hospitalized with
covid has now been placed on a
ventilator according to a tweet from
Nashville's super talk 99 7 WTN the move
to the ventilator was made out of an
abundance of caution
the station's tweet goes on to say the
host made the decision to be put on a
ventilator to give his body some much
needed rest Valentine had previously
been on oxygen now in terms of the rest
I think when you're on the ventilator
you're also sedated so maybe it maybe
it's all as much about that I don't we
just don't know it's sort of a cryptic
way to say it
um the statement from the radio station
States they are confident he will pull
through and thank everyone for continued
prayers in a July 11 Facebook post
Valentine confirmed he tested positive
for covid he spoke about his battle with
the virus on his show I think I'm on the
other side of it he said as he described
coughing congestion and fatigue that
hurts like crap he said I'm certainly
moving forward but not in a straight
line
Valentine previously expressed
disagreement with mask mandates stating
hospitals were never in danger of being
overwhelmed by coveted patients that's a
conspiracy theory it's completely untrue
he's been critical of the vaccines
voicing concerns over safety Mark
Valentine Phil's brother spoke with News
2 earlier this week at the time he said
Phil slightly improved but said we
haven't turned the corner to recovery
yet he went on to say Valentine would be
the most pro-vaccine person you've ever
seen when he returns so listen it's good
that Phil Valentine is now a pro-vaccine
I hope that he recovers and is able to
be a pro-vaccine Advocate because he
would be speaking to his anti-vaxx
Tennessee audience this is exactly the
group that needs to hear hey look at
what happened to me go and get yourself
the vaccine but this is another
cautionary tale I take no pleasure in
the fact that Phil Valentine is now even
sicker I'm hoping that he gets better
and part of why I'm hoping he gets
better is not because I think he doesn't
you know it's not about not resenting
his anti-vaxxerism I resent it but if he
does recover and becomes a vaccine
Advocate it could actually save lives
because he's going to be speaking to
exactly the people who need to hear it
we'll have more on this on our Instagram
page make sure you're following us there
at David pakman show and follow us on
tick tock
yeah can you believe it almost 50 000
followers on Tick Tock also David Pacman
show there
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today Nick majuli who is CEO at
rith Holtz wealth management and also
founder of of dollars and data a data
focused personal finance blog to which I
subscribe great to have you back on Nick
okay nice to see you again David so okay
uh many in my audience are millennials
or they know Millennials or they've
heard of Millennials at least and
um are probably familiar with some of
the headlines that say Millennials
dramatically worse off financially than
their parents than their grandparents
the millennial generation is just
financially a disaster oftentimes
student loans combined with stagnant
wages are pointing to
etc etc okay so that may be true I think
I want to understand how these things
are being calculated first and foremost
so maybe let's start there when those
headlines are written what are they
based on
they are based on so one of the big um
stats that people use they look at the
share of total wealth that every
generation owns and so the Federal
Reserve basically says okay here's one
generation they just use years and ages
and years and you know here's Boomers
here's Gen X here's Millennials Etc and
they just say like what percentage of
the total wealth do they own by these
estimates and the percentage that
Millennials own right now is smaller
than the percentage that Boomers owned
at the same age and smaller than what
Gen X owned at the same age the only
issue with that is the pie has gone
considerably bigger right so that's
that's something to consider and then
you also have to look at like okay and
just for inflation you have to adjust
for the number of households there are
now there are I think more Millennials
and Boomers but at one point I mean you
know you go back five six years that
wasn't the case boomers are the largest
generation but you know as as that
generation dies off you know Millennials
have basically are taking over so I
think there's some truth to that there
is truth to the student debt loads
there's truth to you know stagnant wages
those things are happening but I think
you have to look at a much much broader
picture I think those are they're
focusing on a very small selection of
Millennials and not the entire if you
look across all Millennials you kind of
aggregate things and look across the
entire generation I don't think it's as
dire as the media makes it out to be so
make that case I mean how can we how do
you defend empirically the idea that
Millennials actually aren't aren't so
poorly off
yeah so if you look at
inflation-adjusted per capita per
household net worth the same I'm using
the same data source that they use to
say Millennials are poor using the same
data source from the Federal Reserve you
look at those Trends over time and I
would have to I could send you a charter
it's in my blog post but there's a chart
which shows like okay here's where
Millennials are here's where Boomers
were at the same age and like the lines
are lining up it's like they're on the
same trajectory it's like people are
just getting older and you know that
we're gaining more wealth like even
during covid the thing I remember it's
like Millennials added one trillion
dollars in total wealth to their
generation during covid which was
obviously a very bad time financially
for a lot of people so we hear this
stuff and like I'm not saying that there
aren't people struggling I'm not trying
to debate that that's definitely true
and I can in the data we see that
clearly the bottom 10 of the millennial
generation of younger households in
general are far far worse off than any
bottom 10 10 of the younger Generations
previously and it's because of debt
loads it's because of
um you know job prospects there's a lot
of reasons why this is happening but you
can clearly see it in the data so if
you're looking like yeah there's a lot
of people struggling and if you focus on
that segment you can write stories about
that which are legitimate at the same
time to then paint that subset to the
rest of everyone else I don't think it's
completely fair and so I'm just trying
to bring a little bit more balance and
like more object more objectivity to
this kind of discussion now when we talk
about the other thing is some of these
terms when we talk about wealth are we
talking about assets or are we talking
about net worth because in for example
inflation could lead to people having
more assets in a nominal sense but then
if you account for liabilities then it's
not so so I think it's important to
understand what we're looking at yes we
were I apologize when I was talking
about those charts and wealth I'm
talking about net worth assets minus
liabilities and so like yes Financial
assets are higher but um debt is also
higher yeah non-mortgage debt is higher
for Millennials without a doubt if you
look it's even and they're taking it on
earlier than than Gen X did and they and
which who took it on even earlier than
the Boomers did right so looking at
those types of charts you can see that
like yes we are we have more depth than
any other generation but at the same
time we do have a little bit more
financial assets so it kind of evens out
on on aggregate but I remember aggregate
isn't what people feel people feel their
personal situation sure and just brush
it away but I don't think it's as much
of a crisis as the media portrays it
that's that's I think where I'm kind of
getting at let's pick one kind of sub
issue within all this that's sometimes
talked about like for example home
ownership and that's another one where
you will often see Millennials are uh
have a lower home ownership rate than
prior generations and then there will be
people who say well yeah that's because
the cost of living has gotten
significantly out of sync with wages and
then you add to that the college debt
and then you also add to that that
people are just getting married later on
and so there may be sort of cultural
reasons how how about an issue like that
how should we be thinking about the real
significance of home ownership for
Millennials yeah so I think you brought
up a lot of the key issues there are
people getting married later that's a
cultural reason and it's usually what
when home ownership you know would
happen like for example I'm 31 and
single right now if I were to I could
buy a house but then like if I end up
getting married in the next couple years
or something I'm going to need a bigger
house so I would just pay the
transaction cost to do that so I know
I'm not going to be buying anytime soon
until you know that part of my lifestyle
is more um you know cemented that's so
cultural reasons are true in terms of
you actually look at rent uh rent over
income levels those levels haven't
changed that much you look at you know
after tax income you know divided or
divided by rent you can look at that
ratio those ratios are kind of flat and
so I did look at that in some way so
rent is not necessarily all that much
higher so I wouldn't say that like okay
wages were stagnant if you look at this
analysis like five years ago this is
very true but since like 2014 2015
things have kind of boomed and like
incomes have gone up a lot and a lot of
these stories that were written in 2013
2014 2015 they don't look as true now
because using the same data I have if
you you go and stop the story in 2013 it
looks pretty dire for Millennials I'm
not gonna lie but you moved forward five
years it's like oh things have caught up
you know things are starting to happen
and it isn't looking as bad now and so
that's kind of the thing I see so in
terms of home ownership yeah there's a
lot of issues there and you know
obviously prices have gone up but rates
are lower so like the the cost of a
mortgage may not necessarily be that
much higher or similar but it's it's a
complex topic there's a lot of issues to
unpack there so big picture I mean what
what is the kind of defining uh
narrative overall about how we should
understand the financial picture of
Millennials in the aggregate
understanding as you say that people
people's personal experience is their
lived experience and that that's sort of
what it's going to feel like at the
individual level at the aggregate is is
there not much of a story in terms of
how Millennials are doing relative to
Prior Generations financially
I don't I don't think I think it depends
when you look right as I said if you go
back a couple years it looks pretty bad
but now things have have you know
incomes have gone up a bit like you know
assets have gone up as a result because
of that Millennials aren't looking as
um as they don't look like they're
struggling as much however I think the
real story to take away here is there is
a subset of Millennials that is
struggling and I think they need help
and so whether that's right now the
there's debates about whether we should
cancel student loan debt or right we
should have why not have a tax credit
every American gets a ten thousand
dollar tax credit that you can use
towards education if you never use it
you lose it if you've used it in the
past you can use it in the future right
if you paid off student loan debt you
know 10 years ago guess what you can use
it you can write it off that you know I
don't know exactly know how that would
work but something like that where it's
going to feel Fair everyone gets it
technically you know and it would help
those people that are in debt at least
somewhat so I don't know if that's the
solution but I think there are people
that need help and painting the picture
of oh all Millennials are struggling I
think that makes Boomers look at
millennials oh they're just lazy versus
like no just some Millennials are
struggling then Boomers may look at this
and say oh that's the real problem we
should help them I think it's it's much
easier to help a subset of people than
to be like Oh I'm not just going to do a
massive wealth transfer to Millennials
which I don't think we need I think it's
like any sort of thing like that I think
it needs to be very targeted to the
people who are actually like in a really
bad position yeah I mean that's one of
the criticisms one of the criticisms
that comes up about the just the blanket
cancellation of student debt is that it
wouldn't really be that Progressive and
I'm not saying politically Progressive
I'm saying in in terms of you know who
it's who it's hitting because there are
lots of people who uh have chosen to
take on debt even though even though
their financial position today is
actually quite good and you're going to
be hitting them even though their
ability to repay is actually significant
is that a fair criticism of like a
blanket student debt cancellation versus
something like what you're talking about
yeah so I see the issue is like okay
personal responsibility oh I chose not
to go I mean you have to realize like
what is it only a third of Americans end
up getting a college degree anyways and
so like you know for me I'm obviously in
a bubble where like most of my friends
are college educated so like to me it's
like oh everyone has a college degree
but remember it's only about a third of
Americans yeah creating a policy only
for a third of Americans is something
that like and it's not like age-based or
something like Social Security it's it's
something that's going to be hard to
pass
um that's why I'm saying like try and
come up with something that's like Fair
maybe you come up with a policy where
you can use your these credits for a
technical school you can use it for
anything you can use it for a coding
boot camp you know if you expand it to
not just be college debt I think you can
get a lot more Americans in on it and it
would actually help people so I think
you need to just rethink that and that's
also one of the reasons why like yeah
canceling student loan debt well that's
that would be helpful to some people I
think a lot of people will see that and
say like yeah that's I why am I paying
for someone else's thing so I think you
need to kind of make it a little bit
more fair to get a lot more buy-in from
from everyone I don't know how to do do
that but yeah
the Andrew Yang idea was to include
trade school and that's not unique to
Andrew Yang just his name comes to mind
I know Joe Biden has talked about that
that as well and so have others I mean I
think the cultural issue around the
cancer you've got the economic issue
where there are some on the American
political right who say well it just
shouldn't be done because either we
can't afford it or people haven't earned
that cancellation because they chose to
go to school they knew what it cost Etc
there's also the political cultural side
of the perception that college is
left-wing indoctrination and so there's
some resistance to that because there
are people who politically on the right
thing well if you encourage more people
to go to college that's actually going
to be a problem politically and that's
probably another hurdle that would have
to be cleared of course yeah both of
those things I think the fiscal
arguments make more sense than the
indoctrination arguments obviously yes
the universities are more liberal for a
host of reasons but I don't think it
necessarily needs to be indoctrination I
don't think it needs to be that strong
no but I do think the fiscal arguments
you can make those like yeah can we
afford this this and that I think there
are probably some multiplier effects I
haven't really read all the studies on
this but I think education is generally
good of course if you go to you know do
what the joke is underwater basket
weaving you know that's probably not a
good use of resources but I think a lot
of you know a lot of educational things
are I think generally positive for
society yeah I mean I think when you
look at the range of the the how
stimulative different types of
government spending uh um is slash R I
don't know grammatically what the right
word is there
um on the one hand you've got like
letting rich people who have all of
their expenses covered just put more
money in the bank account right that
that would be on the low end on the
other side things like food stamps are
extremely stimulative in terms of a
multiplier effect and we can imagine why
the money's going right back into local
businesses and and it's increasing it's
a demand side stimulus in communities I
think education tends to be closer to
the food stamp side than the letting
rich people sock money away in a savings
account side
um
yeah I I would tend to probably agree
with that I mean I haven't looked at the
studies on it but yeah I mean I think
education is probably closer to that
than
um something that's not really helpful
Nick um while while we have you here
because you've written and tweeted a lot
about your ups and downs with
cryptocurrency and if I recall correctly
a few months ago you got out right I got
half out you got half out half out yes
what is your sense now of what we're
seeing you know I recently did an
interview with um the CEO of Celsius who
obviously has a vested financial
interest in saying this is only the
beginning this is going to be great as
someone who is half out and you sort of
have a casual interest in it would be
cool if that went up what you still have
but but it might not what's your sense
of what it's looking like the role of
cryptocurrency is going to be in the
bigger Financial picture going forward
I have no idea I think that that
question if I knew if we knew the prices
would reflect that whether that's up or
down right if we knew it's not going to
be that useful like there's still a lot
of people saying I don't see how a lot
of this stuff's useful there's some
people saying oh well this is going to
take over the world everyone's going to
be using Bitcoin for everything I think
the truth is somewhere between the two I
don't think it's the most useful thing
ever and I don't think it's absolutely
useless either
um and the reason I sold wasn't because
I have some sort of Market Outlook I was
just like I bought it with a it was
supposed to be a certain percentage of
my portfolio it grew I got it at 8 000
it grew it was up at 52 when I sold half
of it and I paired that half off to get
back to a fair allocation of what I feel
comfortable with I can't have I mean it
kept growing it's just and that's what
happens it got too big and I've sensed
now that the prices have come down I
said okay well the allocations got
smaller you know I'm also looking at I
looked at ethereum a little bit I said
maybe we'll get some of that so now I
have a little bit of an ethereum
allocation instead of my half Bitcoin
just because yeah prices drop enough I
will buy more cryptocurrency to kind of
keep my allocation and it's a very small
allocation but it's something that I
believe even I run some data on it and
we'll see we'll see what happens
obviously no one knows the future but
yeah yeah I mean that sounds similar to
my position I mean I think at more than
10 years in there's no reason for me to
think this is going away and even as
different governments have have done
have changed policy in different ways
it's still not going away and the number
of individuals holding at least some
seems to have gone up so for me and this
is not Financial advice I've said it's
like a three to four percent type thing
in terms of in terms of asset allocation
yeah that's exactly kind of the way I've
kind of looked at it you know it's like
find a small percentage I remember if
I'm we're not here to give full
Financial advice of course bulk of my
investments are in income producing
assets there's gonna be like stocks
bonds real estate stuff like that so the
bulk of my wealth is in there and that's
what I recommend for people what
percentage that's kind of up to you what
you feel comfortable with
um but yeah so I just I don't know
what's happened with crypto but if it is
a revolution if it is a revolutionary
thing that's going to change the world
this is kind of what you should expect
with prices like it's not just gonna
we're also gonna wake up tomorrow I'm
like okay we're all going to agree that
this is the price no it's going to go up
way past that price it's going to crash
below it's gonna oscillate upwards until
it Finds Its its final price and maybe
it's too high relative to where its
equilibrium should be maybe it's too low
if it's like a digital gold it's far too
low right now if it's not additional
gold it's maybe too high I don't know
right so that's that's the truth we have
been speaking with Nick majuli who runs
the blog of dollars and data now here's
my request to people in my audience if
you disagree with what Nick says tell
him where his data is wrong no ad
hominems please
um yeah my v-neck don't attack my
background exactly exactly uh Nick's
also c-o-o at redholtz wealth management
Nick always great to talk to you great
to talk to you as well David
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so one of
the Republican members on this house
select committee that's investigating
the January 6th Trump riots Adam
kinzinger uh essentially admitted to
Wolf Blitzer last night on CNN that
other than one or two Republican elected
officials none of them actually believe
that Donald Trump won the 2020 election
it's not a surprising admission but I
would make the point that it's actually
worse that despite not believing it they
continue mostly to allow the claim aim
to spread publicly and we'll get back to
that but before we look at the video
just as a sort of reminder there was a
proposed January 6 commission that was
going to be 911 style as the way it was
described it was proposed months ago it
was going to be truly bipartisan in the
sense that we would all sort of agree
that it's bipartisan which meant that
there were going to be five members
chosen by the Democrats five members
chosen by the Republicans the chairman
uh would be a republican a Democrat
rather because Democrats control the
house
Vice chair would be Republican every
subpoena would have to be signed off on
by both the Democratic chair and the
Republican Vice chair Republicans said
no whole bunch of reasons why they said
no many of them bogus we've talked about
it before So eventually we get to this
house select committee which is
investigating and in this one House
minority leader Kevin McCarthy said
here's five Republicans were putting on
it two of them were Jim Jordan and Jim
Banks who really should be Witnesses or
they're potentially accomplices in the
riots they have no business
investigating them and so Nancy Pelosi
the Speaker of the House rightly said
they can't be on the commission
ultimately
um uh we saw Republican Adam kinzinger
and Republican Liz Cheney placed onto
this panel and
um on after the first day during which
we heard from four different uh members
of Capitol Police last night Adam
kinzinger was interviewed by Wolf
Blitzer on CNN now it's really important
as we watch this clip
Adam kinzinger is talking about elected
officials don't believe Trump really won
this is not about Republican voters
that's an important distinction which
we're going to talk about in a second
but let's start with the uh interview
here and
um very very important points made we
can get to answers have any of your
Republican colleagues I'm just curious
uh actually privately said to you good
work I support you yes oh yeah is that
just one or two is it a handful or or
give us a give me a ballpark number uh
you know because over time I don't know
it's there's a lot of people you know
and uh that come up and say it and it's
not any of the ones that you know go on
TV and and spout the big lie and then
say it it's the ones that are staying
more quiet that I think appreciate the
stand
um but it's a lot and look what's the
thing to keep in mind save one or two
maybe out here nobody and I think it's
very important to repeat nobody actually
believes the election was stolen from
Donald Trump but a lot of them are happy
to go out and say it was are you still
comfortable being a member of the
Republican Party have you given any
thought at all maybe of switching
parties as you uh you're gonna have to
seek re-election next year yeah no no
look I'm a republican at heart right I
was a republican way before Donald Trump
since I was six years old I believe in
the values I'm six-year-old by the way
we could explore that six-year-old
Republican but let's not right now
fighting for and I believe that a party
was such a great Rich history deserves
to have people even if it's only a
couple of us at the moment in their
fighting to restore the soul of it so
I'm gonna fight hard for that so let's
let's think about this I I essentially
believe that Adam kinzinger is right
here I think there are almost no actual
Republican elected officials who think
Trump won the 2020 election they're not
good people because privately they don't
believe it they're actually bad people I
would say I mean you know it's it's a
simplistic term but what the point I'm
trying to make is I would respect them
if they came out and said this is a lie
this is the Joe Biden won we might not
like it I'm not a Democrat but Joe Biden
won this is Republicans saying this
privately believing that Joe Biden won
but not coming out and saying it and
allowing it to be perpetrated and
perpetuated and and uh blown up and
Signal boosted by your colleagues I
would argue that that's actually even
worse and I know that there are some
people who will hear this
and they'll say I knew that most of
these Republicans had a good head on
their shoulders I knew it they couldn't
really be so dumbest to believe that
Donald Trump actually won the election
they're actually they're okay people no
no no no it's even worse that they are
allowing something like that to be
continually spread discussed signal
boosted and reported as if it's news
when they don't actually believe it and
the most infuriating part and this is
where we have to distinguish between
Republican politicians and Republican
voters
it is not true that Republican voters
don't believe it the Republican voters
do believe it they are pulled on it
regularly and so these Republican
elected officials who maybe they
privately know that Donald Trump didn't
actually win
they are allowing or even participating
in misleading their constituents because
it keeps them politically relevant it
keeps them on Trump's good side which
they think maybe they're going to need
in 22 or in 24 if they know it's a lie
then why are they spreading it or
allowing it to spread and it's because
they know that a lot of the voters
believe it and the voters believing it
probably is beneficial to them in terms
of getting themselves re-elected and
um the the the voters believing it is
having a real impact you know when when
I drive by this house a few miles away
that has this huge 12-foot wide by you
know 10 foot tall Trump flag in the yard
that says Trump won they really do
believe it and we see the polling and we
see that tens of millions of these
people believe that Donald Trump
actually won so great there are
Republicans who are in moral or amoral
enough
that while privately they know Donald
Trump didn't actually win they either
say publicly that he did or he might
have or they shut their mouths and allow
the Republican Party voters to continue
spreading that idea
um they aren't good people because they
privately know the truth they are bad in
the sense that they don't come out and
say hey guys I might disagree with
Democrats on taxes abortion foreign
policy whatever but the president of the
United States is Joe Biden because Joe
Biden won the election period fair and
square end of story and you know I'm not
surprised to hear Adam kinzinger said
he's willing to say it unfortunately
many of his colleagues may not believe
it but they're still willing to allow it
to spread like a virus within the
Republican Party hey this is really
really bizarre this may be one of the
biggest most jarring instances of saying
that a is actually b or that two plus
two equals five or that you know
that double speak reminiscent of of
George Orwell I told you yesterday that
there was a really important race
Tuesday in Texas's sixth congressional
district it was a runoff where a trump
endorsed Republican went against another
Republican not endorsed by Trump and the
Trump endorsi lost not by a crazy amount
but by about six points it was a there
was no question that they lost and this
was our first signal about is Donald
Trump going to be able to play kingmaker
in 2022 Trump needs to successfully be a
king maker in 2022 to have a better shot
at running in 2024 and to continue
raising money and to continue at the
head of the Republican Party etc etc uh
and now Trump is calling it a win it's
just it's absolutely bizarre there's a
very interesting article
um in axios where Trump spoke to
Jonathan Swann on the phone listen to
this Trump's advisors are angry at David
McIntosh president of the conservative
Club for Growth for persuading Trump to
endorse a losing candidate in the
special election for Texas a sixth
district so first of all it's blaming
others why it matters Susan writes
defeat Tuesday in a Republican runoff
with navy veteran Jake Elsey dealt a
blow to Trump's Aura of invincibility as
a republican King maker it's critical to
his 22 midterm endorsements and
continued hold on the Republican Party
Trump advisors and allies have been
ambivalent about the club's advice and
thought he should stay out of this
Republican on Republican contest they
take the Long View and are protective of
his successful records so far in
Republican Party primary endorsements
Macintosh did not respond to repeated
requests for comments but this is the
wacky part
Trump himself disputed the result dented
his power in a phone call with axios on
Wednesday the former president conceded
Macintosh had pushed him to support
right but blamed democrats for Elsie's
Victory he also said he actually won day
is night black is white Up Is Down
he said he won because right bested LZ
in the initial primary and the runoff
came down to two Republicans he liked so
Trump is doing revisionist history he's
saying well okay I of these two
Republicans I endorsed one and that
Republican lost that might look like I
lost but no I actually like both
Republicans so really it's a win now of
course this is absurd because if that's
the way Trump saw it then he shouldn't
have endorsed anybody uh and this is
incredible revisionist history Trump
then goes on to say I think this is the
only race we've lost together
Trump said of Macintosh and the club for
work for growth before catching himself
mid-sentence on the word lost this is
the only race we've this is not a loss
again I don't want to claim it as a loss
this was a win the big thing is we had
two very good people running that were
both Republicans that is the win Trump
is notorious for shifting or refusing to
accept blame for any failure whether as
a businessman or as a politician the
Club for Growth spent more than one
million dollars on the runoff making it
easily the top outside spender so what's
interesting is you and I are going to
look at this and we are going to
evaluate it on the merits but even
losses Trump is calling wins and he's
completely divorced from reality uh
Maggie Haberman from The New York Times
sent an interesting tweet which was the
biggest complaint Republican candidates
who might run in 24 have is that Trump
gets a presumption of strength he
doesn't actually have any more
we don't actually know yet for long term
of Republican party but last night was
an unequivocal loss in a race he didn't
need to step into also some conspiracies
starting quickly Maggie Haberman writing
there are also some interesting
conspiracy theories going around right
now in trumpland blaming various
Republican senior electives for why
right lost for example are people
intentionally trying to diminish Trump's
clout uh and my reaction to that is of
course there are conspiracy theories
starting to spread this is a loss for
Trump let's see what happens on the next
one in building up this picture of how
influential he will or won't be he could
also be influential but in the negative
sense that he influences people to lose
by giving them an endorsement it could
end up being like an anti-endorsement
it's just too early to tell
uh we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P here is a
voicemail from someone saying Hey would
covid be taken seriously by the right if
it became flesh eating it's actually a
good question hey I'm Carl from Midland
New Jersey and I had a thought about
people that are upset with covid
and I thought was
I does the thing have to maybe mutate to
the point where
it makes body parts fall off or
is like a flesh eating virus my point is
for people to quit being in denial yeah
and it takes something like that for
everybody to all be on board about how
bad this disease is I do think that if
covid mutated to become flesh eating and
the death rate went up to 10 percent
which would be a global tragedy of
historic proportions by the way you will
see more people on the right take it
seriously but not all no matter how
crazy you think we've seen them be there
will always be some holdouts and even if
covid became a 10 death flesh-eating
disease you would see the deniers
continue to deny it's an unfortunate uh
problem in the United States we'll talk
on today's bonus show about the Simone
biles Olympic situation we will talk
about the hundred dollar uh cash offer
for New Yorkers New York City uh
residents getting vaccinated and we will
talk about Florida Mayors who were defy
Ron DeSantis with mask and vaccine
mandates all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com I'll see you there
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors ground news is
combating divisiveness in media ground
is a news comparison platform that helps
you see multiple perspectives for any
news story so you can be more of a
well-rounded news reader download the
free app at ground.news Pacman